[Musique]
et on parle à présent de ce sujet
d'envergure pour le territoire des
Yvelines aussi celui de 50 ans en
Yvelines et Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent
tout prochainement un peu plus d'un an
désormais avant cet échéance olympique 4
sites des JO qui sont implantés sur le
territoire de 50 ans divine on va faire
le point avec vous le remasouris sur les
travaux l'avancée des travaux sur la
colline d'Élancourt voir aussi quel
projet sera donné par la suite à ce site
pour donc son avenir et après ces Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 des travaux
préparatoires avaient débuté l'an passé
sur la colline on va dire des travaux
qui sont entrés dans le concret depuis
janvier est-ce que ça avance bien depuis
là c'est la réalisation de la piste
olympique qui est en cours du côté de la
colline il y a deux phases pour faire
simple il y a la phase avant Jo il y
aura une phase très importante après les
JO pour la phase d'héritage vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure le but c'est
d'ouvrir cette colline au plus grand
nombre ensuite mais j'y reviendrai et
bien la première phase elle est
aujourd'hui quasiment terminée nous
allons enfin le solideo qui est
l'organisme qui s'occupe de permettra de
piloter ces travaux va bientôt remettre
les clés à Paris 2024 là dans quelques
jours pour qu'on est réalise début
septembre le festivalt puisqu'on a la
chance d'avoir sur Saint-Quentin le seul
test grandeur nature qui sera réalisé de
fonctionnement d'un site olympique on va
essayer bien entendu la piste on va y
tester les infrastructures la qualité
des travaux réalisés mais on va y tester
également tout ce qui tourne autour et
qui permet aussi aux épreuves d'avoir
lieu c'est à dire aussi bien la partie
informatique télématique que la sécurité
que les transports que l'arrivée en vélo
etc tout va être testé et ça aura lieu
dans le week-end du 24 septembre
prochain en même temps que l'Open
d'ailleurs de France de golf c'est aussi
une gageur effectivement et le golf en
plus au programme bien sûr olympique de
ces JO on a vu quelques images de
l'entrée du chantier de cette colline on
va peut-être pouvoir voir aussi hein
c'est solideo la solideo qui les a
révélés les premières images du du
parcours on reparle on reprécise que la
seule idée c'est la société de livraison
des ouvrages olympiques là sur la
colline on va avoir une une piste de
premier plan puisque elle sera sur ces
Jeux Olympiques et chose importante elle
sera aussi conserver dans le tracé après
de des après les Jeux Olympiques tout à
fait la phase d'héritage elle a deux
parties enfin les travaux liés à
l'héritage en deux parties une partie
ouvert au grand public pour tout le
monde puisse se promener en coexistence
avec les vététistes ce qui est une
gageur parce qu'on sait que parfois ces
sources de conflit entre la montagne ou
les vététistes ont du mal à coexister
avec les piétons là pour le coup les
deux existeront et donc dans le cas des
pistes de VTT vous aurez la piste noire
qui sera directement
héritée de la piste des Jeux Olympiques
et puis on décline un peu comme au ski
des pistes jaunes vertes bleues et
rouges et les pistes noires nous
permettront ensuite de revenir utiliser
ce site éventuellement pour y faire des
championnats de France ou des
championnats du monde au fil des années
qui qui viendront donc vous l'avez dit
pistolympique très prochainement livré
en vue du Test Event qui aura lieu à
l'automne 2023 sur sur cette piste
olympique de la colline à quoi ça va
ressembler très concrètement le test
even ça va être vraiment une répétition
générale avant les Jeux Olympiques alors
c'est une répétition générale avec un
petit peu moins de monde on y attend
entre 3000 et 5000 personnes alors que
nous attendons 12000 personnes pour la
phase vraiment des des deux jours je
rappelle que c'est seulement deux jours
d'épreuve là le Test Event a lieu grosso
modo sur trois jours et on va vraiment
répéter la totalité de tout ce qui
pourra fonctionner et j'espère entre
guillemets qu'on aura des choses qui ne
fonctionneront pas parce que sur les
choses qui ne fonctionneront pas ça nous
permettra au contraire de capitaliser
dessus pour encore améliorer l'accueil à
la fois des sportifs des journalistes
puisque ils seront nombreux à Élancourt
pour ces épreuves mais également et
surtout de tous les tous ceux qui
viendront visiter du coup le territoire
à travers leur présence sur ce site des
Jeux Olympiques même si à l'issue de ce
test event il y a il y aura une
finalisation des travaux des
aménagements en vue des JO ça va se
poursuivre jusqu'au printemps 2024
exactement ça se poursuit je comprends
le temps 2024 ensuite on rentre en phase
où on arrête tout intervention sur le
site et surtout ça reprend après les JO
pour une année complète de travaux et
donc au cours juste après les yeux
pardon vous avez parlé de la phase
héritage ma question c'est de savoir
pourquoi c'était important pour ce site
qui était autrefois fermé au public en
l'ouvrait pour des événements il y a eu
des trails il y a eu la revancheur de
Sia une épreuve bien sûr cycliste
pourquoi c'est important pour
l'agglomération de pouvoir lui donner un
avenir et l'ouvrir aux habitants la
réponse elle est quasiment dans la dans
votre question on avait un site immense
le point le plus haut de l'Île-de-France
il remonte à son sommet on voit tout
Paris et on voit une grande partie de la
banlieue parisienne et d'ailleurs aussi
bien vers l'ouest toute la partie verte
et aujourd'hui il était fermé
officiellement public beaucoup de gens
s'il faut filer et il y en avait pas le
bénéfice que la population peut en
attendre alors que c'est un site
emblématique pour 50 ans de vie pour
Élancourt et pour l'Île-de-France en
général donc il fallait l'ouvrir et en
cela les Jeux Olympiques ont été comme
pour beaucoup d'autres choses un vrai
vecteur qui va bien au-delà du sport
parce que les JO c'est un peu de sport
mais c'est beaucoup d'aménagement et
beaucoup d'équipements territoriaux et
dans le cas de la colline Delancourt ça
nous a permis en fait d'avancer
quasiment de 30 ans ce qui aurait pris
un nombre incroyable de temps si on
avait voulu réaliser les travaux qui
sont sur place je rappelle que c'est un
des rares sites ou une sera couler aucun
gramme de béton et à l'inverse c'est
probablement le site qui reçoit le plus
de compensation écologique puisque dans
les 12 millions 200000 euros de travaux
plus de 3 millions d'euros sont
consacrés au compensation écologique qui
commence une fois que le site aura été
utilisé par les JO et qui a commencé
déjà aujourd'hui par la suppression des
cette espèce invasives qui empêchait une
nidification en particulier de tout ce
qui était rongeur et des oiseaux donc
juste après les Jeux une nouvelle phase
d'aménagement a priori en 2025 la
colline sera ouverte normalement le
train c'est d'ouvrir à la rentrée 2025
septembre octobre 2025 à la fois au
vététiste et à l'ensemble de la
population avec les habitants qui ont
été associés dans une phase de
concertation il y a eu différentes
phases on avait parlé ensemble il me
semble sur ce plateau de la
participation du public par voie
électronique c'était l'an passé comment
ont été associés juste pour revenir sur
cette phase de concertation les 50
chinois dans dans la réalisation de ces
projets alors il y a eu un certain
nombre de réunions publiques j'allais
dire c'est assez traditionnel mais je
pense que là les échanges ont été vif et
passionnés il y a eu également des
réunions faut le savoir en amont je
pense aux associations écologiques
d'Élancourt avec lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé c'était très inquiète au début
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui elles peuvent
voir et constater la qualité des travaux
réalisés encore une fois ils ne sont pas
terminés je pense que vraiment l'effet
waoud un point de vue écologique sera
pour après les JO et lors de ces
différentes réunions il a été tenu
compte des uns des différents tour qui
avait été fait pour amender le projet à
la marge mais c'est souvent dans le
détail que se situe en fait le plus
grands risques et donc ce sont tous ces
petits détails additionner qui nous ont
permis de corriger un salon d'idées a
priori quand on travaille sur un plan
c'est pas la même chose que contre un
travail dans la réalité du terrain je
pense aux différents domaines également
il y a des problématiques de proximité
on a un immeuble au pied de la colline
côté lencourt on a deux domaines de
pavillons qui sont à la fois sur plaisir
et également sur la commune des longs
qui sont vraiment en rive avec
l'aménagement il fallait rassurer mais
il va falloir montrer également que les
engagements qu'on a pris que la solideo
a pris on sera capable de les réaliser
pour pouvoir à la fois être à proximité
d'habitation et en même temps d'ouvrir
au grand public c'est une vraie gageure
et je pense que c'est une vraie réussite
et 50 ans Yvelines pour cela
historiquement et probablement et à
cette chance là d'être très doté en
matière de collaborateurs une
collaboratrice qui sont capables
d'anticiper des aménagements de haute
valeur à la fois urbanistique et très
vert et donc on rappelle le calendrier
donc très prochainement livraison de
cette piste olympique un Test Event qui
aura lieu à l'automne 2023 cette année
sur cette colline Élancourt et ensuite
de nouveaux aménagements en vue des
suivi de la phase d'héritage donc qui va
se dérouler d'octobre 2024 et vous le
disiez objectif d'ouvrir à la rentrée
2025 pour ces aménagements
héritage et donc l'engouement on le
disait qui monte autour de ces Jeux
Olympiques il y a d'autres échéances
bien sûr qui vont arriver sur le
territoire 50 ans de vie on a suivi très
dernièrement la tournée des sites
olympiques qui était passée par le
vélodrome le Golf National là c'est
passé par le stade de BMX il y a des
événements forcément qui vont jalonner
l'année jusqu'à jusqu'à cette échéance
olympique très prochainement la journée
olympique je crois olympique
effectivement qui va avoir lieu au mois
de juin mais qui est très importante et
qui reste un événement j'allais dire
récurrent maintenant sur le territoire
ça a commencé avant les Jeux Olympiques
ça continuera bien entendu après puis
faites à nous à votre mouchoir le 23
juillet 2023 départ de la dernière
épreuve du Tour de France qui partira
tout à côté du siège et TV 78 depuis le
vélo de Rome national je pense que c'est
un grand moment on est très heureux
d'accueillir le Tour de France on aura
le Paris-Nice l'année prochaine on a qui
lui également partira du territoire et
traversent le territoire on a luci track
Champion League ça peut paraître un mot
un petit peu barbare mais c'est en fait
la Coupe du monde de cyclisme sur piste
qui a été revisité et donc il y aura
lieu au mois de novembre et puis le 28
et 29 juillet 2024 avec les épreuves je
cite le VTT puisque on parlait de la
colline d'Élancourt et donc le VTT
qu'ils auront le droit à ses épreuves
fin juillet sur la colline d'Élancourt
Philippe femme forcément les champs
olympiques vous l'attendez avec grande
impatience peut-être pour le basket mais
pour le sportif que vous êtes en général
d'autant plus que quand on accueille les
Jeux Olympiques c'est une chance
importante de pouvoir effectuer d'une
part qualifier l'ensemble de ces équipes
nationales mais également de travailler
en vue de je dirais d'obtenir des
médailles et les meilleurs résultats
pour autant le sport est ce qu'il est et
je dirais c'est le plus fort qui gagnera
mais pour autant il est vrai que
bénéficier de de sites en France et
avoir une préparation de quatre années
ça permet d'envisager de bons résultats
pour la France les premiers matchs
auront lieu du côté de Lille et après ça
viendra seulement sur sur Paris est-ce
que tu ne peux pas être fait sur la
région parisienne dans la mesure où il
n'y a pas suffisamment de je dirais
d'endroit qui permettent d'accueillir
autant de nations et puis ça va être
d'abord délocaliser puis ensuite ça va
être rapatrié finalement sur la région
parisienne et je rappelle un J moins 437
désormais avant le lancement de ces Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 merci Laurent
mazori d'être venu parler de ces
aménagements en cours sur la colline